i've held many men on my bosom after sex
you want to be held
i know gilbert wants to be held i know
it i know it
shut up don't even play cool guys
i like my hair being played with uh-huh
okay okay worse no it's fantastic
shame this [ __ ] sensitive wonderful
being and also yeah i uh yeah i like the
hair i don't like the cuddling because
my arm when she wants to always do that
there we go it goes out
you don't lay on her chest i don't care
which direction the cuddling goes it
doesn't here's the thing if i lay on her
chest i just go to bits i start going
like
stuff like that but what's the point of
it george what about you i wonder what
the point of [ __ ] cuddling is
connecting no no it's a waste of [ __ ]
time physically
and you're going
what is there to do i feel so rewarded
by it
oh okay i think there's a difference
between i think maybe fundamental
difference between love
i love you
i know you're very good at the words and
i'll touch your foot and i say i love
you
she's like croc yeah yeah george what
about you
oh i love to be little spoon
see oh so you do like being cuddled okay
what's a little spoon man he's on the
inside of the spoon oh yeah that way
your arm doesn't do you cry too you
little [ __ ]
oh my god you crawl into a little fetus
position you cry like and you're [ __ ]
sweating little [ __ ] spoon me
i'm not i've never been more alpha when
i demand no you know what you do no
that's not spoon me later i know what
you do all right okay
i'm not getting my hair fiddled with uh
like come on after you make love dude i
know you you start tearing up i tear out
i know but he does for a man right
and his tears are like i can't believe a
woman let me do that again
right which is cool and it's to god
because that's a freebie or whatever
right so that's i can't believe it right
that was amazing it's almost as if what
that guy did when he in that movie um
um where he climbed the mountain
um um
it's the same thing you know i mean
where he got up there was like i can't
believe i did that
it's the same feeling so and then
he's so grateful right
look at this science shows that people
who love cuddling have a proven
advantage over everyone else that
doesn't help what's the average what's
the advantage yeah i don't i don't wanna
yeah i don't wanna good news spooners
what a study first really turn this out
this is [ __ ] right-wing propaganda
yeah steve bannon [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you bannon so what i'm saying is
that let me i'll tell you and then when
george
his wife
right yeah
looks at her and he goes this look at
this little piece of [ __ ] crying like a
[ __ ] baby that's what you think his
wife said yeah yeah but she says
internally outwardly it would be rude
and he's like and he's shaking he's in a
fetal position he's crying right little
spoon and he's like
little spoon
and she goes [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i want to say it's a word about what she
thinks but i can't say it i can't
imagine your wife doing this i know her
and it's just [ __ ] f word right
and then she just
you know she does it
but she you know in her head there's a
time limit
yeah do you ever notice that when she
does that
three minutes tops
and then she has [ __ ] to do like life
stuff and that catered somewhat to
a weak little [ __ ]
a weak little [ __ ] i'm sorry i'm
kidding you're you're a good guy and
your heart is big incredible
congratulations you know what's
happening tonight
some definite cuddling no we're not like
if you don't want to do traditional
cuddling you also have to eat something
there's different types so you don't
have to necessarily have you done this
one with her before what's that one
where you go behind her and you hold her
yeah when we make pottery
you know we her and i don't make pottery
like he goes a lot of ceramics right we
have the music and we do it i go behind
her and we make the pottery so what's
another position uh this is an
intertwining leg one yeah
yeah
we do that on roller coasters i'll tell
you
so we can lock into each other so that
we'll fly out this is this is an actual
conversation we have